Taylor Swift and Joe Allen's PGA Tour
finally John Cena proves why he is a big
ol softy when it comes to fiance Nikki
Bella Plus chance the rapper reports the
weather everybody hope you had a fab
weekend I'm finally feeling fresh as a
daisy but we are still in holiday party
mode so hang in there I'm talking to
myself right now someone who looks like
they are feeling the Christmas spirit is
Taylor Swift she has virtually kept her
boyfriend Joe Allen in hiding but we
finally got a taste first PDA with Joe
holding hands on their way back from
Taylor set at Madison Square Garden for
Jingle Bell
[Music]
that song was written about Joe and by
weekends and the PDA toward continued
across the pond and here's hometown of
London at Capital FM's Jingle Bell Ball
now during Ed Sheeran's performance Joe
had his arm wrapped around Taylor as
they were grooving to his set and her
British boy clearly loves her hits to
because he was spotted grooving and
filming his lady last night as well now
the two have been together for a year
now and will soon celebrate Christmas
together and I personally love how
low-key they've been I think it suits
them boy do you guys think let me know
in the comment section and I will say
I'm giving them a 7 on the John and
Chrissie scale from now extra point for
a fanboy over your girl Joe alright now
another star just completely spent over
the woman in his life John Cena the WWE
star turned actor plays Ferdinand a bull
who is misunderstood in the new animated
film John shattered a big misconception
about himself as our Deidre Behar found
out at the LA premiere you think they
got you all figured out based on how you
look that's simple I think over the
years of misconceptions are being
shattered one by one you know I do have
a bold and sometimes Stern exterior with
the WWE but moments like me proposing to
Nicole in front of 75,000 fans at
WrestleMania lets everybody know that
yeah there's there's times to be tough
but this you're never too ashamed to say
what is it about that moment that just
kind of brings tears to your eyes well
that's the greatest poem in my life it
was like worlds colliding WWE has been
my family for the last 15 years and the
Kohl's the woman I want to spend the
rest of my life with it's it's the best
moment of my life
now is it just me or is John serving us
some buddy the elf vibes in that moment
[Music]
all right thank you
right well that doesn't make you feel
all warm and fuzzy inside
maybe this will chance the rapper has
won multiple Grammys hosted SNL and now
he can say he has successfully
forecasted the weather chance stopped by
local news station WG
TV and tried his hand at being a
weatherman and I'd say the coloring book
wrapper passed with flying colors in
Kenosha it's 19 degrees yeah you're on
it 19 at Waukegan as well similar 19
over at O'Hare 19 actually 20 now at the
lakefront 19 still look Midway a lot of
19's going on yeah
oh and due to the Peruvian perches
apparently Peru as in here just in case
I have to check out books at the
Hogwarts library could do that yo listen
I need chance to come and do my job
consider this an open invitation the
daily chance room for it I prefer him
over me all right guys thanks for
watching today keep on liking ensuring
and we will be back tomorrow with
another dose of baby Danny so goodbye
for now
[Music]